good morning good morning so here we are
the Supreme Court including the
president's appointees have declared
that he is not above the law the point
the path that the Supreme Court has laid
out is one that is clearly achievable by
us in the lower court and we will
continue to go down that path the
decision enables it to enable the Trump
administrations I don't know what
they're even saying about it I hear he's
tweeting one thing and then other people
are saying another but whatever it is
it's not good news for the President of
the United States it is a path that we
will take so I put in a statement I
don't see it here do we have a copy of
this thing do we it's not here
so but anyway you'll you don't need me
to give you a piece of paper to have
what the statement is but it took me a
little longer to get out here because I
wanted to read to the bottom the end of
the decision and Chief Justice
specifically speaks to the fact that the
president is not above the wall and that
was something that was proclaimed in the
decision including two of his recent
appointments a careful enormous a
careful reading Supreme Court ruling
related to the president's financial
records is not good news for President
Trump the court has reaffirmed the
Congress's authority to conduct
oversight on behalf of the American
people as it asked for further
information from Congress Congress's
constitutional responsibility to uncover
the truth specifically related to the
president's Russia connection that he is
hiding the Congress will continue to
conduct oversight for the people
upholding the separation of powers that
is the genius of our Constitution we
will continue to press our case
in the lower courts that's what happened
this morning
earlier this morning for the 16th week
in a row over 1 million Americans
applied for unemployment insurance 16th
week in a row we have to open up our
economy we can only do so by killing off
the virus that's what's in the heroes
Act testing tracing treatment separation
masking wash your hands
keep your distance as I said that is
what is in the heroes Act there's the
science all of the scientific
pronouncements have spoken to the need
for more testing and the urgency of
tracing and the benefit of treatment so
that people do not die again
this administration seems to be turning
its back on science and instead saying
open up take a risk
oh by the way open up the schools open
up the schools as a mother and a
grandmother we all everybody I know
wants to open up the schools indeed a
large percentage overwhelmingly the
teachers want to open up the schools but
it has to be safe for the children and
to be safe for the children we must
attack this coronavirus we must kill it
off we cannot ignore it and we cannot
call it a hoax and we cannot
misrepresent the facts that's what the
status of it is in order for their
children to go back to school our state
and local governments have to function
that's what the heroes Act is about the
first piece of it honor our heroes state
and local government hiring our our
first responders our teachers our
teachers our teachers our health care
workers who
risk to their lives so that other to
save other lives and now they may lose
their jobs over a million public
employees have lost their jobs in the
course of this coronavirus and we
couldn't change that if we makes a
commitment in the heroes act to state
and local government and by the way go
there
speaker gov / heroes act and see how
much money goes to your community your
state your locality or County your
municipality and then recognize that it
is only one-half of what the Republicans
gave to the top one percent in their tax
scam and their tax scam cost twice as
much as what we want to spend to open up
government to provide the services that
people need to open up our economy into
an to open up our schools Secretary of
Education indicated that children should
go to school they have to take risks
everybody takes risk take risk to ride a
bicycle to be an astronaut there's risk
you have to take risk no we don't want
our children to take risk to go to
school we're supposed to mitigate for
any damage we're supposed to keep them
safe so with stiff competition that was
one of the most ill-informed statement
stiff competition though in this
administration on this and other
subjects and the third part of it is
we're never going to have our economy
come back unless we recognize that we
must put money in the pockets of the
American people and that's what we do
with the third pillar of the of the
heroes Act unemployment insurance will
expire in a few weeks in July
unemployment insurance will expire the
heroes Act extends it extends it and
again the last checks go out about July
26 something like that but it's over by
the end of the month we must renew
unemployment insurance
this morning 16th state week straight
week of 1 million people over 1 million
people applying for unemployment
insurance and we have to put the money
in the pockets of people with our direct
payments absolutely essential if we do
not if we do not help our state and
local governments honoring our heroes if
we do not kill off this virus and if we
do not put money in the pockets of the
American people our economy will only
worsen don't take it from me take it
from authorities on the subject who
track this all the time so it's
absolutely essential absolutely
essential that we come together in a
bipartisan way and get this done in the
next few weeks it also has in there are
resources that had bipartisan support in
the country for helping the post will
serve you the postal service going
keeping voting at home funded and also a
very important part of putting people
back to work
our OSHA provision for safety in the
workplace PPP and its availability or
lack thereof is very much a part of
everything we've been talking about
about meeting the needs the health care
needs of people who are diagnosed it's
essential to our our teachers and our
children going back to school teachers
custodians all of those who are
responsible for the education of our
children which is a the highest priority
for us all safely PPP necessary and
again we have a shortage of that so we
have to have common sense weigh in on
this common sense to listen to the
scientist and not CDC regulations that
are predicated on a tweet on a tweet
what we always want any guidance that we
get to be updated by this
if acknowledged and the rest but this to
be downgraded on a tweet just tells you
how senseless all of this is as we're
gathering here this week or the many
things are going on the Appropriations
Committee is meeting every day starting
Monday of the next two weeks putting
together our appropriations bills which
as you know must be passed by September
30th that's the deadline the and the
Armed Services Committee is meeting I
think right now as we speak and they're
being briefed on matters that relate to
Russia the right now today I guess it is
continuation of the work of the Energy
and Commerce Committee that is having
its hearings appropriations Homeland
Security or these are the subcommittee's
of appropriations Foreign Affairs
Committee on Europe is having its
hearings education and labor a major
examining the impact of coab 819 on the
future of higher education financial
services the economic perspectives on
alternative approaches to protecting
workers drunk ovid 19 Oversight
Committee goes into the life-threatening
impact of single-use plastic on human
health and then in natural resources
there's a meeting of Democrats only on
the restoration economy examining
environmental and economic opportunities
the list goes on Homeland Security small
business budget Veterans Affairs Energy
and Commerce I said and they're like
three days of the of these of these
meetings so I'm very proud of the work
that the members are doing to prepare us
for the votes on the floor when we call
all the members back Intelligence
Committee when we come back we'll be
marking up the intelligence bill but it
it is all in the works now so we're
we're getting ready for when they come
back and as I say many of these meetings
are virtual some are high
some are actual all of them important
and all of them to be acted upon when we
come back including the appropriations
bill and almost immediately the National
Defense Authorization Act the urgency
the urgency is more than urgent it's
it's so necessary and so obvious of the
heroes Act demands it's an imperative of
that we put something together that
passes out of the Congress signed by the
president by the end end of July
so that we are people who have
uncertainty in their lives because of
unemployment uncertainty in their lives
because of just not having resources
will have the comfort of knowing and
therefore the consumer confidence to
spend which is so important but anyway
just very eventful time sad about the
again the one the 16th week of people
applying for unemployment insurance
carefully reading the Supreme Court
decision and responsibilities four of
them that they lay out for the Congress
which we will abide by in the lower
courts and again seven to two even the
president's appointees saying President
of the United States is not above the
law a year can you tell you tell us if
you've spoken with him about this day
like a departure from his initial
comments where he was saying you need to
wait and see before there's more
spending and now does that make you more
open to liability protections no next no
let me just say this every day you see
them opening up more we get overtures
about can this be in the bill can that
be in the bill because they know there
has to be a bill
what is not doesn't measure up is oh it
can only be a trillion dollars no we
need a trillion dollars for state and
local when you a trillion dollars
another trillion dollars for
unemployment insurance and direct
payments we don't know something like
that but probably not as much for the
testing tracing treatment etc so
trillion dollars is okay that's that's
an interesting starting point but it
doesn't come anywhere near I don't know
where the $40,000 came from I think
there are many families depending on
size of family but so many different
things that the $40,000 would have to be
explained justified in the rest but I
think families making over $40,000
probably need assistance and just
spending on their family situation the
we think there's a path to talk about
protecting businesses and workers and
customers who come in and that is our
OSHA a provision but and let's hear what
everybody has to say but don't say you
all have to go back to work even if it
isn't safe and by the way we're removing
all responsibility from the employer I
mean I know billion a but you just a
trillion for what trillion for what no
no I'm saying trillion trillion for
state and local trillion for
unemployment insurance and direct
payments trillion with a TR let's put it
this way one trillion dollars for state
and local that is half of the cost of
the Republican plan in their tax scam
where the cost added two trillion
dollars to the national debt so yeah I'm
saying trillion and let me say another
thing about trillions the Fed is
spending trillions of dollars to shore
up
to shore up the stock market that may be
a good thing to do we think we should
spend trillions of dollars to shore up
America's workers and that there's a
path that is a good investment that is a
stimulus that is stimulus that keeps
people from losing their jobs and helps
people get jobs by being a stimulus in
spending having consumer confidence
spending and jected demand into the
economy job creating Chad and then what
will the house do business I mean
differently
you would have conceivably had these
records committee and you would have to
prevent you from doing some sort of a
broader investigation which some
Democrats will tell you privately that
they would prefer not to go down that
road this before to work but we have a
path that the Supreme Court has laid out
that we certainly will not ignore and we
will never stop our oversight that is
our responsibility under the
Constitution of the United States yeah
the by all accounts for many of the
shall we say constitutional authorities
this was there was never any way they
were going to give us the records right
now but they would give us a path to the
records yes sir very unlikely the
election before the election so are you
disappointed that Congress and the
American public will not see these
records almost certainly will not see
these records before November well thank
you for that question because it takes
me to
was really important about this decision
this isn't so much about the president's
records although we'd like to know you
know how Russia funded his operation all
of you but that's not what was it stick
what was at stake as the president above
the wall is this court the court
friendly to the president going to rule
in favor of the executive branch and say
that there is no congressional oversight
undermining our system of checks and
balances so for us that was what was
important and what is at stake is the
system of checks and balances as I say
in my statement the genius of the
Constitution if in fact they would have
ruled that he is above not above the law
I mean that he that he can do whatever
he wants without any oversight from
Congress that would have been a just
devastating to tell you the honest truth
and we would still fight it we would
still fight it because they would have
abandoned all precedents and the rest
that has ruled in favor of Congress
having oversight Authority however they
did not and the victory is for the
Constitution of the United States the
process will take longer but that's not
what the the important what was truly
important here all I kept thinking is
our founders did this magnificently
magnificently the separation apart of
checks and balance the separation of
power it co-equal branches of government
and the court sustained that this
morning given the unemployment situation
and the rise in cases in the past couple
of days do you think it's possible to
extend that unemployment benefit
separate from the heroes Act or some
other package that you may have to work
out before the end of the month the
people ask me is it possible that you
could do the state and local separately
or acknowledging the heart of what's
happening with a spike in the spikes in
the coronavirus would you do that
separately they were
we are all connected they are all of one
piece we will be working on in our
budget committee has has been making
progress on this on how we have
stabilizers so that if you reach a
certain unemployment rate or whatever
measure is appropriate to the action
required that it will automatically
happen so that there's no doubt but this
unemployment insurance uncertainty is
devastating to families so the I don't
know you know I don't know if that's the
easiest thing I don't know that they
support unemployment insurance but I do
think that they will eventually support
state and local government and they're
going to have to come around to
something on Kovich by the way much of
what we have on these testing tracing
treatment etc relates to addressing the
disparities in our community how low
income families and people of color
suffer in a disproportionate way because
of their predisposition to it because of
their lack of access to testing early
enough and the rest so every piece of it
is critically important and there's no
reason why we shouldn't should we just
ignore testing and let this thing go
should we just say to state and local to
bad fire people fire people diminish
services to your populations and also
raise taxes I mean this is a very well
thought-out initiative and it's all
connected open up the economy test treat
the people honor our heroes it's all
connected and the other women have a
question no yes ma'am
we're putting together appropriations
bill now I think with the president's
withdrawal from wo is senseless it's not
only about the coronavirus it's about
polio it's about other afflictions
diseases diagnosis that we have worked
together to try to eliminate or diminish
so I think it's senseless as you know it
doesn't become effective until next
summer practice 2021 I think it is July
I will be addressing it in our
appropriations bill that is being
written this week and next to counter
that yes sir on Tuesday the HHS
appropriations markup congressman Cole
criticized the fiscal spending year our
neck spending bill for forcing Family
Planning guarantees to provide
information on abortion to all pregnant
women they serve regardless of their
religious belief I just wanted to get
your thoughts on that I haven't seen I
haven't seen that I I don't know what he
said about it but when I see it I'll let
you know what I think of it to be able
to take out the Hyde Amendment well let
me just say this about the Hyde
Amendment for 40 years since I was like
not even in Congress have been dismayed
by the injustice of the Hyde Amendment
it's just discriminates against poor
women and largely they are women of
color and so I don't know if that
relates to that I don't know what that
is I don't I don't think that it's in
the bill I don't you'll have to possibly
remove the Hyde Amendment in the coming
spending bills in the years to come
well what are we talking about the years
to come I myself would like to see it
gone gone I think it's gravely unjust
but it's not in this bill as I
understand so what was he come
about something that wasn't in the bill
he was complaining about criticizing
that the family planning guarantees to
provide information on abortions to all
pregnant women that they serve
regardless of their religious belief I
don't know I mean I just don't and I'm
an appropriator and I served on Labor
HHS for many years and I'm very close to
the issue of family planning being a
mother of five in six years to the day
but I don't know what he's complaining
about there yes ma'am this question is
close to home for you the city of
Richmond is obviously in sync with your
Confederate statutes but in Bob's lost
somewhere in Little Italy the statute of
Christopher Columbus was removed
taken down well I'm not a bit you know I
don't even have my grandmother's
earrings
I'm not a big let's see what we have in
terms of monuments in this I'm more
interested in what people have
accomplished I think that it's up to the
communities to decide what statues they
want to see but I think that it's very
important that we take down any of the
statues of people who committed treason
against the United States of America as
those statues exist in the Congress of
the the halls of Congress in the Rotunda
the not the rotunda I don't think but in
the statuary hall and the rest promote
many some of them are but I'm not one of
those people whose wedded to Oh a statue
it to somebody someplace is an important
thing I don't
again if the community doesn't want the
statue there the statue shouldn't be
there I miss my pride in my Italian
American heritage and the fact that it
was a country discovered by an Italian
name going Italian America Vespucci
so I have that pride but I don't care
that much about statues
we'll do what they do it's a it is I do
think that from a safety standpoint it
would be a good idea to have it taken
down if the community doesn't want it I
don't know that it has to be a
commission I but it just could be a
community view and sometimes it's
something that's been there that view
has been there for a while but let's
just say I always say to young people
who come to the children he'll come to
the capital when you look around you see
statues to people in Washington
monuments and the rest who who respect
my finkin Jefferson Lincoln you know
heroes they would want us to be talking
about the future your future so
everything we do here is about you it's
not necessarily they would want it to be
about looking forward not looking back
so let's just think about what are the
values the vision the perspective that
we enshrined and how that benefits our
children rather than having a big fight
about what somebody worth it we know
they're not worth it if they committed
treason against the United States thank
you all very much